[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لماذا تخلت مصر السيسي بكل هذه
السهوله والليونه عن جزيرتي تيران وصنافير
الاستراتيجيتين عند مدخل خليج العقبه
للسعوديه وهل اصبحت حدود الدوله الم
الضاربه في عمق التاريخ ترسم وفق مبدا ام
التلي وماذا قالت له عن ام الرشراش
المصريه التي احتلتها اسرائيل وسمتها
ايلات وماذا قالت له عن مثلث حلايب
وشلاتين الم يطالب به السودان مرارا
وتكرارا وقدم وثائق وكان له وجود فيه ام
ان الرز السوداني لا يصلح لمعده النظام
المصري وحتى لو كانت الجزيرتان غير
مصريتين فهل تخلت اسبانيا عن سبت ومليليا
المغربيتين هل هل تخلت بريطانيا عن جبل
طارق الاسبانيه والفوقان الارجنتينيه
يتساءل مصريون ولكن في المقابل ما كل هذا
الصداع على جزيرتين لم تمارس مصر عليهما
السياده فعليا منذ عام 67 ومن قال ان مياه
مضيق تيران هي بحر اقليمي لمصر اذا كانت
معاهده السلام المصريه الاسرائيليه نصت
على انه ممر دولي مفتوح للاسرائيليين
وغيرهم ومن قال ان نقل السياده للسعوديه
سيسهل لاسرائيل
بناء قناه منافسه لقناه السويس من البحر
الاحمر الى البحر المتوسط مشاهدينا الكرام
نرحب بكم وبضيف الاتجاه المعاكس هذا
الاسبوع معنا الاستاذ محمود عطيه المحامي
رئيس ائتلاف مصر فوق الجميع ومعنا ايضا
الاستاذ سليم عزوز الكاتب الصحفي فاصل
قصير ونبدا النقاش في حلقه هذا
الاسبوع
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقه هذا الاسبوع من
الاتجاه المعاكس نناقش اتفاقيه التعيين
الحدود البحريه بين مصر والسعوديه قبل ان
نبدا النقاش نتوجه مباشره الى هذا المقطع
الذي يظهر مشاهد التصويت على هذه
الاتفاقيه في البرلمان المصري هل الموافق
على اقفال باب التصويت يتفضل برا
الع الموافقه على ما انتهى اليه تقرير
اللجنه بشان الاتفاقيه يتفضل برفع اليد
يتفضل
بالوقوف الموافق يتفضل
بالوقوف المواقف يتفضل
[تصفيق]
بالوقوف
اذا
ان ليتفضل السيد المقرر ليتفضل السيد
المقرر ليتفضل السيد المقرر بتلاوه
القرار ليتفضل سيد
المقرر السيد المقرر بتلا
القرار يك
قرار
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم وفق على اتفاقيه تعيين الحدود
البحريه بين جمهوريه مصر العربيه والمملكه
العربيه
السعوديه بتاريخ 17 7/42
2016 اذا الموافق على اتفاقيه ترسيم
الحدود البحريه بين جمهوريه مصر العربيه
والملكه العصبيه تفضل وبرفع
اليد موافقه ا اذن اعلن موافقه المجلس على
اتفاقيه ترسيم الحدود البحريه بين جمهوريه
مصر العربيه والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الموقعه بتاريخ 8 ابريل سنه
2016 وهذا اذا ما اعلنه علي عبعال علي عبد
العال رئيس البرلمان المصري ا معلنا
موافقه مصر على تعيين الحدود البحريه بين
السعوديه ومصر وهو ما يعني في
النهايه انتقال السياده من جزيرتي تيران
وصنافير المصريتين الى السعوديه نبدا
النقاش اذا مع ضيفين في هذا الاسبوع وابدا
بالاستاذ محمود عطيه المحامي رئيس ائتلاف
مصر فوق الجميع هذه هذه الطريقه التي نقلت
بها السياده الى و وع على جزء عزيز على
كثير من المصريين ولا اقول كل المصريين
المفروض ان هو يكون عزيز على كل المصريين
لكن جزء من التراب المصري الذي ظل جزءا من
التراب المصري في عصور في في حياتنا
المشهوده التي طلعنا لقينا طيران وصنافير
مصريه هذه الطريقه التي انتقلت بها
السياده بهذا الشكل هل انت رضل
عنها وفقا
لل للقانون
الدولي انا ماليش راي في الرضا او عدم
الرضا في على انتقال السياده لان اصلا ما
فيش سياده على في اداره ما فيش سياده وفق
ما ما ما ظهر في في الاوراق وكلام
المسؤولين المصريين
و في
ا رئيس مبارك مضى على الاتفاقيه سنه
90 وانا شايف ان دي مش دي يعني مش مش اول
مره يحصل فيه ترسيم حدود بين دول بين
السعوديه ودول السعوديه رسمت حدود مع
الامارات مع عمان مع العراق مع قطر وحصلت
مشكله مع قطر وتدخل الرئيس مبارك في سنه
92 حاجه زي كده
وحصل اتفاق في السعوديه يعني يعني مساله
مش جديده يعني على على على ترسيم الحدود
ايه الجديد في كده ولا هي مصر لما بتعمل
حاجه يبقى عجبه واذا كانت هي
ا تقول ل
للسعوديه يعني ايه ايه الخطا في كده ايه
الخطاف كده هل هي تقول للسعوديه ما هو في
في
حضرتك في حكم محكمه قضاء الاداري ماذا قال
حكم الم ال قال انها مصريه كويس اليوم
بمناسبه حكم المحكمه القضائيه اليوم ايضا
صدر حكم من القضاء الاداري يقول بشكل واضح
انه حتى احكام القضاء التي لجات اليها
الحكومه وهي احكام احكام القضاء المستعجل
التي لاجات اليها الحكومه المصريه باطله
ولا ولا تعطل الحكم النهائي البات الصادر
من القضاء الاداري بان الجزيرتين
مصريتان مفوضي المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
قالوا ان الجزيرتين مصريتان وحده برلمان
السيد عبد العال الذي قال انه القضاء لا
يلزمنا واحكام القضاء لا تلزم لا هو هو ما
قالش كده للامانه بقى الحته دي بالذات لو
سمحت لي وتديني الوقت اقولها سريعا كده
يعني القضاء الاداري ده اصلا قضاء فرنسي
واحنا بنتعامل بالقانون الفرنسي وبناخد
الخبرات من القانون
الفرنسي القضاء الاداري في ده بتاع
الحكومه ا خرج خرج من عنده وهو اللي ابتدع
موضوع السياده ليه عشان ما يحصلش تعارض مع
الحكومه بيفت نفسه القضاء الفرنسي
بالسياده فالسيا هنا الاتفاقات الدوليه
معروفه كلها انها سياده
ف القضاء ض الاداري بيتس ويضيق وفقا
للدوله من حيث الديمقراطيه لان كون ان
الدوله تسمح للقضاء ان يتصدى لهذا الموضوع
فده ده ده للدوله مش مش ضد الدوله فتصدى
القضاء الاداري والاداريه العليا وحكمت
حكم وتصدى القضاء المستعجل وحكم حكم
بالغاء الحكم الحكمين
راحوا الدستوريه كويس وبعدين الحكومه
نقلت الملف الى مجلس الشعب اللي هو
الاختصاص الطبيعي في في المعاهدات لمجلس
الشعب مجلس الشعب قال ا سعوديتين لو حضرتك
او الناس المتابعه شافت الرئيس السيسي في
الاسماعيليه المح ان ممكن يعني ننتظر
المحكمه الدستوريه واذا المحكمه الدستوريه
المحكمه الدستوريه تقول اكث من حاجه يا
اما اختصاص القضاء الاداري وما هياش من
السياسه
يا اما اختصاص القضاء المستعجل ولغى يا
اما انها قرار سيادي ومعاهده سياديه وهي
مجلس الشعب ومجلس الشعب اذا قراها يقرها
رئيس الجمهوريه طيب وضحت هذه الفكره اذا
استاذ سليم عز ما المشكله ان تمارس الدوله
وفق الاليات المعمول بها في الدوله
البرلمان القضاء كل واحد شاف شغله وفي
النهايه وصل وصلت كل هذه المؤسسات الى ان
الجزيرتين مش مصريتين وكما قال ناشطون
ورسوم كاريكاتير يعني هندخل على مصر جزر
حرام يعني هذا الذي قيل ما المشكله في ذلك
ما المشكله في تناول القضيه بهذا الشكل
وفق الاليات المعمول بها في القانون
المصري شوف المشكله اننا المشهد الذي
شاهدناه الان منذ قليل هذا مشهد لم تشاهده
ولم يحدث في اي دوله في العالم مشهد ان
يجتمع ما يسمى برلمان من اجل ان يتنازل عن
قطعه من ارض الوطن ده ما حصلش ولا حصل حصل
في مصر ذات نفسها مش ايام عبد الناصر
وايام انور السداد وايام حسني مبارك ده ما
حصلش ايام الاحتلال يعني في ايام الاحتلال
الاحتلال كان حريصا على سياده مصر على
اراضيها وعلى ان تظل الحدود كما هي ومحمد
علي الالباني اللي جاي من اخر الدنيا كان
حريص على عمليه التوسع في حدود مصر مش انك
انت تضيق في حدود مصر الجديد انه ده اساسا
اننا امام عمل من اعمال الخيانه عمل من ا
من اعمال الخيانه لانه الدوله اللي انت
اساسا بتتمط و تكلم على انها تملك طيران
وصنافير ما جابتش سيره ولا فتحت موضوع
والملك السعودي قال انه ولا كنا نعرف اي
حاجه في هذا عن هذا الموضوع السيسي هو لم
يقل ذلك الحقيقه يعني السيسي يعني لم يقل
يعني هذا لم يثبت مساله انه هو لم يثبت
لكن انه قيل ولم يرد عليه يعني نشر ولم
يرد عليه وفيش ما فيش كلام من هو نشر ان
النيويورك تايمز قالت ان مصر اعطت
السعوديه
جزيرتين كهديه على زياره الملك سلمان هذا
الذي نشر شوف هو في في الاساس هو ليست
هديه للسعوديه ه في الاساس هذه اعطيت
لاسرائيل اعطيت لاسرائيل من اجل ان تتحول
هذه النقطه ال ط قبل ان نتحول الى هذه
النقطه لان هذه النقطه سنناقشها فيما بعد
لكن هو محمود قال انه كل الاتفاقيات
والاوراق بتقول ان هاتين الجزيرتين
سعوديتان وانه الملك عبد العزيز طلب من
مصر ان تتولى حمايتها في سنه
1950 لما بدات
اسرائيل تنظر الى هاتين الجزيرتين ومصر
تحميها من هذا الوقت انا عندي ردين على
هذه النقطه الرد الاول انه لم يثبت في
الاوراق انه الملك عبد العزيز او اي ملك
في سعودي تقدم بطلب رسمي الى مصر من اجل
انها تفرض سيادتها على الجزيرتين ده ولا
يقدروا يقدموا هذا الكلام والذي يؤكد على
هذا المعنى ان السلطه في مصر ان سلطه
الانقلاب في مصر لم تتقدم بهذه الاوراق
الى المحكمه والمحكمه الاداريه العليا
قالت في حيثيات حكم انها لم تقدم اليها
وثائق من هذا من هذا النوع وبناء عليه
كان كان الحكم النقطه الا اهم في هذا
الموضوع انك انت كنت في معاهده السلام مع
اسرائيل او توقيع اتفاقيه كانب ديفيد او
في التحكيم او في كل هذه المسائل اللي حصل
انك انت كنت تتحدث على تيران وصنافير
باعتبارها ارض مصريه مش مش لانه مصر كانت
كانت بديرها لانه مصر كانت على سبيل
المثال بتدير غزه وكانت الاداره المصريه
قائمه في غز وعندك قضاه من غزه وعندك حاكم
في غزه هو حاكم مصري وعندك كل هذا الكلام
لما جر اجتياح غزه مع نكس 67 وهزيمه 67
ايه اللي حصل انك انت ما جبتش ما فتحتش
ملف غزه وانت بتتناقش مع اسرائيل في
اتفاقيه السلام وما قلتش هروح التحكيم من
اجل غزه لانه في نهايه الامر غزه مش ارضك
انت كنت تمارس عليها الاداره وبالتالي لو
كانت المساله مساله مرتبطه بانه هذه الارض
ملك السعوديه وان السعوديه سلفتها لمصر
عشان مصر تحميها انا اعتقد انه كان من
الطبيعي جدا اسرائيل تتفاوض معاك على اي
اساس اذا كنت انت اساسا دمش ارضك احنا
قدام سلطه يا سيدي سلطه بتلف ودور لكي
تمارس وتمرر عمل من اعمال الخيانه انت
يعني الاحكام الكلام اللي قاله الاستاذ
محمود استاذ محمود محامي ومعه مكتب ولديه
روب محاماه والكلام ده كله لكن الان يتحدث
على احكام مجلس الدوله كما لو كانت مقاله
راي وانها تمثل وجهه نظر وانه اي حد ممكن
ياخد بيها او ما ياخدش بيه احكام مجلس
الدوله والمحكمه الاداريه العليا قالت انه
هذا هذه ارض مصريه والمحكمه الغت انه
الحكومه تحيل ما هو الحكومه حالت بمقتضى
الماده
122 من الدستور احالت هذا الملف
الى الى مجلس النواب اذا كان اساسا يعني
في الاصل والفصل اللي حصل انه المحكمه
نسفت هذا امر الاحاله يبقى مجلس علي عبد
العال ينظر الامر على اي اساس الاصل ان هو
ما عندوش قرار احاله لانه قرار الاحاله
نسفته المحكمه وحكم بات وواجب النفاذ وما
ينفعش تقول لي اصل محكمه عبدين للامور
المستعجله نظرت هذا الموضوع لانه دي طريقه
مبارك ومسلك مبارك انه لما يبقى في حكم
يروح يوقفه عن عن طريق هذه الجزيرتين يعني
اذا كان مبارك كان مقتنع بان الجزيرتين
سعوديتين قعد 20 سنه القرار اللي انت
تتحدث عنه اللي هو صدر سنه 1990 واودع في
الام المت يناير ا 19 تمام هذا القرار لم
يتحدث عن موقع تيران والصنافير وانما تحدث
عن وضع مضيق تيران نفسه مش تيران وصنف
موضع مضيق تيران ووضع العلامات الخاصه به
الجغرافيه لمضيق تيران وهو المعروف وفق
اتفاقيه السلام انه هو مضيق دولي اتفاقيه
السلام تقول ذلك لكن ما يقوله الاستاذ
سليم عزوز يعني حت حتى ولو حتى ولو اعتقد
المصريون ان هذه الجزيره هاتين الجزيرتين
ليست
مصريتين اليست هاتان اويست هاتان
الجزيرتان مهمتان استراتيجيا لمصر ومنها
القومي الا تعطي هذه الجزيرتان لمصر حق ان
الاشراف على مضيق تيران وهو الممر المائي
الوحيد لاسرائيل من البحر الاحمر ا هل
التخلي عن عن الارض يكون بهذه السهوله هل
تخلت تركيا عن الاسكندرون لسوريا هل تخلت
ايران عن جزر ابو موسى وطنب الصغرى وطنب
الكبرى للامارات هل تخلت روسيا عن جزر
الكوريل لليابان هل تخلت اسبانيا عن سبته
ومليليا للمغرب وجزر الخالدات ايضا هل
تخلت بريطانيا عن جزر الفوكلاند التي خاضت
حربا من اجلها مع الارجنتين وهي اقرب
الجزر الى الارجنتين وتخلت عن جبل طارق
على مدخل البحر المتوسط هل بهذه السهوله
يتخلى بلد عن ارض تعتبر مهمه لامنه
الاستراتيجي ومهمه ايضا لاجيال
المقبله نمره واحد اللي قلته حضرتك على
كلام على رئيس مبارك يحض هذا هذا الكلام
الدكتور مصطفى الفيقي وقال ان مبارك لما
تكلم اثناء
مفاوضات تكمله مفاوضات كاب ديفيد كان نوع
من انواع المناوره عشان اسرائيل وهذا
الكلام موجود على المواقع وعلى موقع اليوم
السبع دكتور مصطفى الفقي نمره واحد نمره
اثنين حضرتك يا استاذ زين هناك فرق ما بين
ان انا اسلم حاجه خارج الاقليم وحاجه جوه
الاقليم الاقليم يبقى انا بتنازل زي الناس
اللي بتقول تنازل او وثله التي ضرب ضربتها
لك هذه يعني هذه اراضي خارج يعني الفق لن
تبعد الاف الاميال عن بريطانيا وبريطانيا
اللي بتتخلى عنها وخت حربا من اجلها ا
خارج الاقليم فما بالك بم بارض ظلت على
مدى مد 60
سنه ح مناهج التعليم المصريه تقول ان
استاذ زين استاذ طب اسمع بس طب اسمع بس
طيب ماه حدود حدود الامارات مع قطر كانت
الحدود
واحده اثناء الترسم مع السعوديه بقت
السعوديه بين قطر وبين الامارات دي حلوه
ومصر وحشه لا حصل تبادل اراضي هذ نقطه
مختف
معلشش اسمحو لي
اسمحولي اساسا دول الخليج بلد واحده لكن
اللي حصل من عبد الفتاح السيسي عمل من
اعمال الخيانه اليسي
لون عبد الفتاح السيسي خانه بمقتضى
الدستور الستور اللي حطه عبد الفتاح
السيسي حضر لو حضرتك ما قلتش كده تبقى
غلطان لان وجهه نظر
كده هل الدول ياذ
محمودلا
ازا
لا حق
ونص شايف دي مناقشه كانت تحصل تثبت حقوق
انا عندي ح المجلس ده المجلس ده جاي
باراده
شعبيه
الت السيسي رئيس ولا ده برلمان ولا دي
حكومه ولا دي دوله والسيسي قال عليها شبه
دوله ق شبه
دعود
نود
الاصول
تض ارضي ض ونص مارحه ل
امبارح والمملكه العربيه السعوديه فوق
الرؤس فوق الرس اول امبارح يعني هي مصر
لما كانت سلطانه وبقت ملكيه وبعدين بقت
جمهوريه الحدود
اتغيرت
را يعني هل الدول بتكتشف كده مره واحده
نصحى من النوم الصبح يعني نقعد سنين عشرات
السنين مدرس لاولادنا لاحفادنا ويطلع
الرئيس المصري جبال عبد الناصر في 67
منورات جمال عبد الناصر قال في 67 هو في
في شك في وطنيه جمال عبد الناصر يعني عبد
الناصر
منورى شها لحظه واحده لحظه واحده يطلع عبد
يقول شغال في السفيه وحش طبعا طب مين اللي
كويسس الخء المصري اللي اصدر حكم قال عليه
ده ارض مصريه اذا كان مشص
يا راجل
سابقه مع كامل احترامي وت للقضاء المصري
دي سابقه لم تحصل من قبل يا استاذ اقرا
اقرا المعاهدات
الدوليه الماده
151 عظيم جد هنقرا الده 5
تسمعني الماده 151 شوف المعاهدات مين رئيس
الجمهوريه هو مش عارفه مين الدوله في علا
يا راجل روح في علاقتها الخارجيه ويبرم
المعاهدات ويصدق عليها بعد موافقه مجلس
النواب دي كلها كلام احناش على خبيل لغايه
دلوقتي وتكون لها قوه القانون بعد نشرها
وفقا لاحكام الدستور اسمع يا سيدي ويجب
دعوه الناخبين للاستفتاء على معاهدات
الصلح والتحالف وما يتعلق بحقوق السياده
ولا يتم التصديق عليها الا بعد اعلان
نتيجه الاستفتاء بالموافقه الفقره اللي
تهمنا في الليله دي وفي جميع الاحوال لا
يجوز ابراب معاهده تخالف احكام الدستور او
يترتب عليها التنازل عن اي جزء من اقليم
الدوله اذا كانت من اقليم الدوله
الدهر صح يا
را
الد كتير
بيشوفوك انت بتحمل امانه ان انت بتحرض
ناس اتقرب الى الله واتقرب الى الوطن انني
ادافع عن طراب هذا الوطن الذي يبدده هؤلاء
الاخزان لحظه لحظه
محمود الذي
يب ان
ذكر هو ذكر نقطه مهمه وهي انه كل الدول
تجري معاهدات فيما يتعلق بالاراضي هنالك
نزاعات حدود طبعا الانجليز يعني خربوا
العالم فيما يتعلق بحدود كل الدول ووضعوا
عند كل دوله والاخرى مشاكل في الحدود
فبالتالي العالم يتعافى شيئا فشيئا من هذه
المشاكل كل الدول تبر معاهدات خاصه
بالاراضي وتبادل الاراضي وعوده هذه الارض
الى هذا المكان وهه الارض الى هذا هذه
الدوله او تلك ما هي المشكله في ان تتم
مثل هذه الاتفاقيه ما هو الخطر على مصر من
هذه الاتفاقيه الخطر على مصر من هذه
الاتفاق كما قلنا ان هذه مياه ستتحول يعني
لما يجي لك واحد زي عبد الناصر او في
مستوى عبد الناصر ويتحدث على اغلاق
المضايق لا يجود له ان يتحدث لان هذه
الارض هذه الجزيرتين بتسليمهم للسعوديه
تحولت المياه الى مياه دوليه وليست مياه
اقليه ماليش حاجه هناك نمره اثنين انه
الخطر على مصر من هذا الكلام انه ما فيش
نزاع يعني هذه ارض مصريه خالصه لاحصل
عليها نزاع ولا سمعنا انه في عليها نزاع
ولا في مشكله عليها ولم يبقى في مشاكل
مشاكل بتاع يعني اذا كان العسكر الذين
يتحدثون على انه كل واحد ياخد حقه وامه جت
له في المنام وقالت له يا ابدي خد اديهم
حقهم يعني اذا كان هذا الكلام جائز طب ما
تتكلم على ام الرشراش هي ام الرشراش اليست
ارضا مصريه دي مش ارض مصريه اتاخدت في 7
الدنيا كلها عارفه انها ارض مصريه ما
تتكلم يا اخي كلم اصدقائه الاسرائيليين من
اجل الحصول على في الخمسينات بعد حرب 8
عظيم جدا تخذت وبعد كده جرى نسيانها تمان
وج الحديث عنها وتحولت الى بناء الى بلات
وكل الحكومات المتعاقبه من 250 الى الان
صهينت على هذه الجريمه التي جرت طيب اذا
كان هذه الارض التي هي تيران وصنافير
بتاعه السعوديه وانت لديك اعلى محكمه في
البلاد المحكمه الاداريه عندك ثلاث محاكم
عليا في مصر المحكمه الاداريه العليا
والمحكمه الدستوريه العليا ومحكمه النقط
واحده من ثلاثه من اعلى المحاكم في البلاد
قالت ان هذه ارض مصريه وان الحكومه
المصريه لم تتقدم بثمه وثيقه تؤكد كلاما
غير هذا وان هذه احكام ويعلم الاستاذ
محمود كمحامي بانها احكام واجبه النفاذ
وبت وخلصنا يعني لما يبقى عندك حكم بالشكل
ده وانت قلت هنروح الدستوريه عشان تفصل
رغم الدستوريه اساسا ليست جهه لفض هذا
النزاع لانه ما فيش نزاع اختصاص في الاساس
لانه دي محكمه الاداريه العليا المفروض
تروح لمحكمه الدستوريه لو في حكم محكمه
نقط مش حكم جنع حدين يعني مافيش مافيش
يعني في اختصاص الدستوريه في فيما يتعلق
بامر نزاع الاقتصاد مش مش حاصل ومع ذلك
رحت دستوريه يا اخي استنى لما مصربه عليه
انا اقول لك انا مصربه عليه لان ترامب قال
له سلم الارض دي لمحمد بن سلمان عشان خاطر
يدشن بها شرعيته وادي الموضوع قال له
نستنى لغايه الدوره الجايه قال له مش
هينفع الدوره اجيه له دلوقتي حصلت ازو بقى
عملها الدنيا كلها سمعتها انت س الدنيا
كلت هذا الكلام نشر يعني الطر على مصر ما
هو الخطر على مصرخ يعني انت ذكرت ان الخطر
انه مضيق تيران سيتحول الى ممر دولي مضيق
تيران وفق اتفاقيه السلام بين مصر وا
اسرايل هو ممر دولي هذا نص الاتفاقيه يمكن
هذه الاتفاقيه اولا هذه الاتفاقيه ليس
عليها اجماع مصري وهذه الاتفاقيه كان يمثل
من وقعها انه يمثل خيانه لدى المصريين
والناس اللي قتلوا انور السداد من ضمن
الاسباب التي قالوها ق لك وقع هذه
الاتفاقيه وهذه الاتفاقيه انت طول الوقت
تتحدث على انها لا يجوز انها اتفاقيه كنت
عايز تغير في بعض في بعض الامور فيها يعني
الاجماع منعقد على انها ما فيش اجماع
عليها يعني تقول ديد كان ديفد ليست ملزمه
للشعب المصري اصلا طيب هذا هذا المضيق اس
خليك معي هذا المضيق مضيق تيران مصر مارست
عليه السياده كارض مصريه كمياه اقليميه
مصريه الاداره الاداره مارست السياده
الاداره كمياه كميا كمياه كمياه مصريه لم
لم تنازع لم لم يكن هناك نزاع على سياده
مصر على هذه المنطقه لا من اسرائيل ولا من
السعوديه ولا من اي مكان يعني مافيش مافيش
قضيه ما فيش قضيه في اي محكمه دوليه ت
تقول ان مصر ان هذا هذه المنطقه متنزه
عليها هذه هذه حقيقه ليه لان هذه حقيقه لا
توجد ورقه واحده اسمح لي بس خ اسال سؤالي
خل اسال سؤالي لا توجد ورقه واحده في اي
محكمه دوليه ولا في اروقه اي مكان في
العالم تتنازع السياده على هذه على هذه
الجزر على اي الاحوال لكن مضيق مضيق تيران
كانت مصر تعتبره ارضا مياها اقليميه مصريه
جزء من القطر المصري جزء من الحدود الدوله
المصريه في اوراق كثيره تلال من الاوراق
تؤيدها اوراق اخرى في في مكتبات دوليه
كمكتب برلين والارشيف البريطاني ا حينما
لو لو لاي سبب من الاسباب الغيت معاهده
السلام بين مصر واسرائيل ونحن نحن لا
نتحدث عن هذا الجيل نحن نتحدث عن اجيال
مقبله والسلم ليس امرا دائما والحرب ليست
امرا دائما ووارد يحدث في اي لحظه ان تلغي
اسرائيل معاهده السلام بين مصر واسرائيل
التي بموجبها اصبح مضيق تيران مضيقا دوليا
مفتوحه للملاحه الدوليه في هذه الحاله الم
تكن مصر في هذه الحاله الم تكون قد فقدت
ممرا مهما وعنصر ضغط مهم على عدوها
الرئيسي الراسخ في عقيده الجيش المصري منذ
قيام اسرائيل ان عدو عدو مصر هو في
البوابه الشرقيه تمام الن يكون ذلك خصما
من رصيد مصر الاستراتيجي في اي مواجهه
محتمله مع اسرائيل وهذه المواجهه ممكن ان
تحدث تمام رد ولا لسه اه رد نمره واحد
برضو الرئيس مبارك لو حضرك تعلم والاستاذ
سليم
يعلم الملك خالد رحمه
الله او الملك عبد الله ايا فيه انا مش
متذكر ارسل في طلب هذه الجزر والرئيس
مبارك ما كناش لسه خدنا طابه رئيس مبارك
اوفد او اوسط او وسط
الرئيس جعفر نميري رحمه الله ان يقول له
يا يا جلاله الملك يعني اهدى شويه لحد مش
عايزين شوشره لحد ما نخلص موضوع طابه ده
من ضمن الحاجات اللي قيلت وبرده في ناس
كتير قالوها عن الرئيس مبارك منهم اللي مش
عاجب الاستاذ سل مصطفى الفيقي اقرا ب اق
موظف السفاره السعوديه في مصر ماليش دعوه
بقى انا موظ انا مش اتهم الناس انا مش
اتهم الناس بالباطل يا انا لا ما تمش
ده احنا في رمضان حتى واخد بالك تمش اي حد
كده شهات ده لا تقبل شهادته وو في حزبه بك
ده ده راي حضرتك النقطه
الثانيه حضرتك اذا
كانت الارض بتاعتنا اذا ثبت ان الارض
بتاعتنا وبعدين برض عشان نبقى متفقين انا
لا مع دول ولا مع دول انا مع القياده مع
جيشي ومع بلدي ومع رئيسي اللي يقولوه لان
احنا مش 95 مليون رئيس يعني انا انا كراجل
مواطن بسيط قاعد مع حضرتك دلوقتي انا ايش
عرفني انا بالحدود البحريه ايش عرفني انا
ايش عرفني انا باتفاقيه ترسيم
الحدود قطر
اشتكت السعوديه منفرده
للمحكمه ليه عشان دي ارض ارض عليها سياده
طب ما كنا روحنا المحكمه دقيقه واحده كنا
روحنا المحكمه ما تروح المحكمه امتى تروح
المحكمه امتى لو كانت الارض دي داخل
الاقليم عندك ما هي
دهورا بالاوراق
بالاوراق شين نفس القصه بالاوراق ط اجب
اجب على هذا السؤال لماذا لم تدع لحظه
لحظه سليم لماذا لم تدع مصر مع بع لا لا
لماذا لم تدع مصر اه السعوديه تلجا الى
التحكيم الدولي واذا كانت هذه الارض ملك
السعوديه تاخذها كما حدث بين البحرين وقطر
على سبيل المثال حينما لجا الطرفان الى
التحكيم الدولي وحكمت المحكمه بجزر حوار
على سبيل المثال ل البحرين رغم ان هذه
الجزر ملاصقه لقطر اذا كنت يعني تحب ان
تضرب امثله بقطر يعني طوال الوقت فهذا
مثال لماذا لم تلجا مصر
ب لماذا لم تلجا مصر لماذا لم
ت التحكيم عشان في خلاف اح يكون خلا خلاف
حصل كان هيحصل قتال على
الحدود
اس هذا
لماذا اخ وعط السياسه السياه
ايه فن
الممكن موره
موره بتقول على بلدك رز وزيت
وبتاع
ال لظه
واحده بالكلام ده خف
عليك اسمع اسمع قول يا استاذ لماذا لم
تلجا مصر الى التحكيم الدولي انا عايز
اجابه على هذا السؤال تلجا ليه التحكيم
الدولي لانه حد ارض تسيطر عليها مصر منذ
مده طويله وتقول ان هنالك ان هذه الارض
ليست يا استاذ زين لماذا لم تنتظر التحكيم
الدوليين اه طب قولي ليه طب هقوللك طيبولي
ليه مصر حتى مافيش في القانون الدولي
وضعيات ما فيش حاجه اسمها انا حاطط ايدي
عليها اصلا نزاع على الارض يا محمود يا لا
بيطلبوها يا عم زين يا عم زين بيطلبوها
بيطلبوها بقى لهم حوالي من سنه 54 او 52
ومن قبل كده
بيطلبوها بيجل وبيسو في الموضوع لحاجات
استراتيجيه وسياسيه انا ماعرفهاش انا
كمواطن بسيط ماعرفها تعرفها طب انت ترفها
ازاي
مياده ل جيش ويه الشعب هو صاحب السياده اه
طبعا الشعب هو صحب سياده طب يعني لو الريس
هيحارب دلوقتي يزيع بيان يقوللك انا هحارب
بكره والدستور بيقوللك ياخد راي مجلس
الشعب مجلس الشعب را الناس مجلس الشعب ص
باعتباري ان مجلس الشعب يمثل عن الشعب
انما ده مش مجلس شعب ده رايك لا طبعا مجلس
شعب ده مجلس الشعب ده جايش مجلس الشعب لا
في في و وفي ناس بتعترض
وهم
الحقش مجلس الش
محم محمود قلت ان السياسه هي فن فن الممكن
ايوه ما هي المزايا التي ستعود على مصر من
هذا
الاتفاق ام ان هذا هذا الاتفاق هو فقط
لارجاع الحق لاصحابه لا في مزايا واذا كان
لارجاع الحق لاصحابه ف فلماذا لا لا ترجع
على سبيل المثال الحلايب وشلاتين والسودان
يتنازع على هذه الارض منذ مده دي ارض
مصريه ماشي داخل الاقليم خليني بس افضلل
ولماذا لا تطالب مصر بام الرش وهي ارض
مصريه لماذا اذا كان السيسي حقاني قوي كده
لماذا لا يطالب بارض مصريه مع اسرائيل
تحتل اسرا مش عارف السيسي عملكم ايه مش مش
عاملي حاجه انا
بسالك الكلام موضع انا بسالك انا بسالك
انت رد على الاسئله بقولها لك لماذا انا
في النيابه ولا لا مش في النيابه عشان
ماتعبش والمشاهد والشاهد لا المشاهد فاهم
انا بقول ايه طب يلا رد افضضل اقول كمل
السؤال ما انا كملت السؤال لماذا لم يطالب
بام الرشراش
ولماذا لم يتخلى عن حلايب وشلاتين وهي ارض
ايضا متنازع عليها مرارا وتكرارا وكل
المصريين يعلم ان هذه ارض متنازع عليها لا
طب اتفضل ام رشراش ده موضوع ثاني ايه بقى
هو موضوع ام رشراش ده ده ده بين ده بين
مصر واسرائيل ده ده مش دوله عربيه طب مش
من حقنا ناخدها يعني حقنا اذا كان اذا
كانت طب ليه السيسي ما طلبش ب اذا كانت
اذا طب ليه ما طلبنا الرئيس مبارك ياخدها
ماعرفوش السيسي خلاصص الرئيس مبارك برا
الحكم احنا بتتلكك للسيسي ما هو قعد 30
سنه سياده الرئيس مبارك برده ولم يغير
حدود مصر ايوه
لم يغير حدود مصر مبارك اعاد الى مصر ارضا
هو والسادات
السيسي اخرج اخرج من الاقليم المصري ارض
فلماذا لا يطالب بام الرشراش المصريه التي
تحتلها اسرائيل وتسميها بلاش قطر دول
الخليج كلها لما بترسم الحدود ده ده شيء
وحش يعني ده مخالف انا مالي دول الخليج
انا بسالك على مصر ما انا بسالك برض مش
امر مشابه م اتامرون الناس بالبر وتنسون
انفسكم يا سيدي انا لا امثل دول الخليج
انا اسالك عن
يعني انت تمثل مصر انا انا امثل المشاهد
الذي يريد ان يعرف هذه القضيه لازم
المشاهد يعرف برض ان
في دول الخليج انا ماليش
دعوه ترسيم الحدود دي ما تدخلنيش في موضوع
تاني هذا
مصالح عنوان الحلقه دي ايه اذا تم اذا تم
لا لا مش عنوان الحران وصنافير متران
وصنافير عنوان الحلقه تمام ولكن ليها
ملابسات فتشابها طب قده المزايا ايه هي
المزايا المزايا يا سيدي اللي انا
ماعرفهاش ولكن بالقراءه و بالاسئله
والكلام ده ان في يعني لما عملنا ترسيم
الحدود مع اوبروس واليونان مش طلع حقل
الغاز اللي هو برده لب المشكله الغاز
الطبيعي اني دي الشركه دي موجوده دي ولا
حاجه مش ده برده من ضمن المشاكل والقلق
اللي الضغطه على مصر فيه ولا ولا ولا ايه
فاهم يعني فاهمنا ايه ايه اللي حصل فهمك
ايه لا لا انت فاهم لا مش فاهم لا لا لو
انت مش فاهم مش هتقعد مكانك انت بتتكلم
بتتكلم في موضوع انا يعني انت بشكل غامض
انت بتقول قبرص ايه ايه اللي حصل مع قبرص
واليونان مش في مش في بعد لما ترسيم
الحدود مش حصل فيه تنقيب عن الغاز وتنقيب
عن البترول والكلام ده كله مش مش حصل ولا
ما حصلش ولا انت ما تعرفش انت قول انت انا
انا اقول ايه اللي انا اقوله هو اناا حاكم
مش انت بتقرا وعارف ايوه انا ما بجاوب انا
بسال اتفضل لا انتش معنى دي فيدي بتخلع
بقى لا انا بسال انت بتسال انت بتقول قبر
السان ايه اللي حصل مع قبر السان يجوز ان
في مصالح في تنقيب هناك عن عن عن عن عن
ثروات طبيعيه ليه ليه لا فين يعني عند مين
في المنطقه دي منطقه ايه اللي هي ايه
صنافير يعني ف فيها حاجات كويسه يعني ممكن
تاخدها السعوديه كده
د دلوقتي ما دلوقتي دلوقتي تبع الامم
المتحده لا تبع السعوديه كده لسه ما بقتش
تبع السعوديه هتبقى ت خلاص اسمع بس ما
دلوقتي انت لا انت تقدر ولا هم يقدروا لحد
لما ترسم الحدود ولا الكلام ده غلط ولا
احنا عايزين نستخف
[تصفيق]
مش
حضك ولا يستخف
بصر اكبرير اكبر من عبد الفتاح السيسي
ومصر قبل عبفتاح
السيسي
بتضرب ال خلاص لحظه معمه ليه سليم يعني
يقال انه هذه هذه هذه الصفقه اجريت وانت
قلت في بدايه الحلقه ان هذه الصفقه اجريت
لاسرائيل ما فائده اسرائيل من هذه الصفقه
اذا كان اصلا مرور السفن الاسرائيليه
مسموح به في قناه السويس وفق معاهده
السلام مرور السفن الاسرائيليه مسموح به
في مضيق تيران وفق معاهده السلام سواء
تحولت هذه الجزر الى السعوديه او الى اي
بلد اخر في العالم فان الملاحه
الاسرائيليه مضمونه في هذا المجال في في
مضيق تيران وفي قناه السويس الخط الملاحي
اللي بيال ان اسرائيل ستفعله قديم انه انه
اسرائيل ستقوم بشق قناه من خل من ميناء
ايلات
الى اسدود على البحر المتوسط ه هذه القناه
هذه القناه الحديث بشانها يعني قديم ليس
ليس جديدا واصلا طالما ان الملاحه مضمونه
لاسرائيل في خليج العقبه
ف فلا مانع من اجراء من شق هذه القناه اذا
كانت التكلفه مناسبه صحيح يمكن ان تؤثر
على قناه السويس هذه القناه على اي
الاحوال لكن بالوضع الحالي باتفاقيه
السلام مصر لا تستطيع ان
تمنع انشاء هذه القناه الا بالحرب مع
اسرائيل شوف اولا الغاء معاهده السلام مع
اسرائيل لا يعني بالضروره اعلان الحرب
واذا كان يعني بالضروره اعلان الحرب فان
مه مهمه الجيوش هي ان تحارب يعني دي مساله
يعني مقطوعا بها نمره اين اذا كنت انا
دلوقتي في وضع الضعيف وموافق على معاهده
السلام يعني على مضد فان انت ليه تحكر على
الاجيال القادمه من انها تلغي هذه
المعاهده وتضرب بها عرض الحائط نمره ثلاثه
اذا كان اساسا في معاهده سلام تعطي
اسرائيل الحق في انها تمر فكوني انا طرف
في هذه المعاهده غير لما يبقى الامر لا
شان لي به كما سيحدث بعد ذلك اللي فوق ده
وده ما هو حتى اذا لم تكن هناك اسرائيل
وحتى اذا لم تكن هناك مصالح سوف تجنيها
اسرائيل من هذا من هذا التفريط الذي جرى
في ارض الوطن وحتى لو كان اي حاجه فلا
يجوز لي اتنازل عن ارضي انا عندي بيت في
البلد هل لانه انا مش ساكن في بيتي في
البلد ده اساسا اروح اكلم ملك السعوديه
وقال له تعالى استلم البيت لانه انا مش
مستفيد بيه ما هو برض ده مع دي استخفاف
بفكره التراب الوطني استخفاف بقضيه انه في
التراب الوطني ده اساسا ده اول حاجه جرى
النص عليها في الدستور انه الماده الاولى
تكلمت على حدود مصر وانه ينبغي الحفاظ
عليها الماده 10 104 فيما يختص بالقسم
اللي خاص بمجلس النواب انه يحلفوا على
الالتزام بحدود مصر وعلى الدفاع عن حدود
مصر وعن اضطراب مصر الماده 100 وكام
الماده 144 في مختص بقسم رئيس الجمهوريه
نفس القسم وفي حدود مصر وتراب مصر وارض
مصر قسم الحكومه الاعضاء الحكومه مجلس
الوزراء ورئيس الوزراء يقص يعني ده معناته
ايه معناه ان هذا اضطراب لوحده بدون اي
تفاصيل ان هذا اضطراب الاصل فيه انه غالي
والاصل فيه انه يجري مهمه القوات المسلحه
دي كلها الحفاظ على طراب الوطن والحدود
على والمحافظه على حدود الوطن لانه طراب
الوطن بدون اسرائيل ما هتستفيد وبدون ما
السعوديه اساسا حتستفيد وبدون اي شيء من
هذا القبيل فالاصل في الاشياء ان تدافع عن
تراب الوطن وانك تحافظ على ت الوطن وبعدين
عبفتاح السيسي كان قدامه ثلاث خيارات يعني
اذا كان عايز يفهمنا انه المساله كده يعني
ماشيه على ان هو حق ومستحق الخي الاول انه
كان ينتظر حكم المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
ولم يفعل الخيار الثاني انه كان يلج سيبك
من الدستور ده نقطعه الماده اللي بتقوللك
ان ترا الوطن ما حدش يقرب دحيته ولا باست
ولا يرده
151 نمره اثنين انه كان قدامه انه يعمل
استفتاء ويلجا الى الشعب صاحب القرار
وصاحب السياده وصاحب الاراده
الجيلك صك جت عندك الفرصه وسبتها وبدلتها
لا ما
بدهاش كلام
ماشي نمره اثنين انك تلجا الى خلاص انت
انت يا راجل شايف انه اساسا انه المساله
حاول تقنع الشعب وانت عندك ترسانه اعلاميه
قول لهم يا جماعه دي اساسا حق المملكه
العربيه السعوديه يلا بينا نروح للاستفتاء
لكن انا بقول لك ان السيسي لو ذهب به بهذه
الارض الى الاستفتاء فلن يجد مندوبا له في
اللجان وان الشعب المصري سيسقط هذه
الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه العار نمره اربعه
الدنيا كلها ضغطت في وشك بالشكل ده وانت
عايز تعمل اي حاجه ال الى التحكيم لكنه ما
اخدش لا بديه ولا بديه وراح لا حكم محكمه
الاداريه العليا ولا راح الافتاء ولا راح
السن الدستوريه ولا راح عمل اي ولا راح
تحكيم ولما عبد العال وفرقته المسرحيه من
اجل ان هو ينتزع يعني قرارا من جهه غير
مختصه لما يجي ما يسمى برئيس مجلس الشعب
يقول لك انه حكم القضاء منعدم ده انت
المنعدم وجودا وعدما يعني في حاجه في
الدنيا اسمها يعني في حاجه اسمها قرار
اداري والاستاذ محامي ويعلم في القرار
الاداري المنعدم انما فكره فكره انه يقول
لك حكم محكمه حكم المحكمه الاداريه العليا
يجي عل عبد العال يقول عليه انه منعدم طب
فين اساسا النص الدستوري بيتكلم على الفصل
بين السلطات فين الكلام على انكم طول
الوقت مصدعنا بقضاء مصر الشامخ ويجري
اهدار حجيه الاحكام بهذا الشكل ويجري
التطور على مقام القضاء بهذا الشكل ويجري
يعني انت دخلت صحفيين تحقيق س وجي وطلعتهم
بالمخالفه للقانون بين المحكمه ب
كفاله بتهمه اللي هو خدش رونق القضاء هو
في يعني فين اهل ميتين ام رونق القضاء
هذذه
القضيه فيها عمليه التول انا بتكلم مع
الاستاذ
محي ما هي ح الا
التس ما هي
حج الاداريه الع ض الاداريه العليا دي
تبطل حكمت المحكمه بتبطل عضويه نواب صحيح
ولا مش صحيح صحيح بتبطل عضويه نواب يعني
احكام القضا وحكم احكام القضاء ماينفعش
يتقال ان هي منعدمه اقوللك
لا الراجل قاللك هيضم دقه واحده مش
سكت
الفرصه الفره طيب افضل الراجل ما قالش كده
الراجل قال ايه هنضم هذ هذه الاحكام الى
الملف اللي جايل لنا من الحكومه وانا قلت
لحضرتك في الاول يا استاذ زين ان المساله
جايه انه اول في سابقه لم تحدث من قبل ان
يتصدى القضاء الاداري لشيء يخص السياده
كويس وهو القضاء الاداري نفسه اللي انشا
السياده وفقا للمحكمه الفرنسيه كويس فهو
ما فيش مشاكل فالرئيس عشان في استقلاليه
القضاء وتقدير القضاء و
يعني القضاء واخد الحجيه بتاعته تمام ما
تدخلش خلاص في ناس رفعت القضاء خلاص رفعوا
القضاء لما رفعوا في في المحكمه الامور
المستعجله ولغت خلاص الاتنين بقى في حكمين
متضادين طيب انت كمحامي ايه حجيه الامور
المستعجله امام القضاء الاداري ايهما اعلى
درجه وايهما اكثر حجيه لا بالنسبه لي
كمحامي بالنسبه
لي القضاء الاداري القضاء الاداري بالنسبه
لي انا بس اذا كان الموضوع
دقيقه واحده بس اذا كان الموضوع يخص
القضاء هي بالراحه كده بس عشان الناس تفهم
والله العظيم انا لا مع الفريق ده ولا مع
الفريق ده انا مع قيادات اللي
بيقولوا يمشي اه
فريق اللي ابطلوا المؤامره على الشرق
الاوسط عشان تبقى عارف واخد بالك ف هي
المساله اذا اذا اذا اذا المحكمه اذا
المحكمه الدستوريه يا استاذ زين قالت ان
حق القضاء الاداري انه يتصدى لهذا الموضوع
فمن حق الذين دقيقه
واحده انا جاي لك اهو يا عم اصبر هو انت
بتعارض للمعارضه من حق الذين اقاموا
الدعوه تمام اذا ما تنفذت الحكم يرفعوا
قضيه على الحكومه وعلى رئيس مجلس الشعب
وعلى رئيس الجمهوريه سلمت م هو لسه مضى ط
هيض ما مضاش لسض يا راجل
انت ابراهيم شفت متم الا
صك
ممكن الانتظار لمحكمه
الستوريه حاجه بالنسبه للرسم مش
هي عمالين تقولوا يعني التراب الوطني
والتراب المصري والشعب المصري رافض والشعب
المصري مش رافض فين الشعب المصري الشعب
المصري اس لماذا لم يخرج الشعب المصري في
ما سمي بجمعه الغضب وكانت هذه الفرصه
الاخيره لابطال هذه الاتفاقيه والتعبير عن
راي الشارع المصري اين هو الشارع المصري
من هذه الاتفاقيه لسبب مهم جدا انك اغلقت
الميادين انك نزلت الجيش والشرطه من اجل
ان يحموا هذا الجرام انك انت اعتقلت ناس
من بيوتها في شباب الى الان ر اعتقاله من
بيوته لانه بتهمه الدفاع عن الارض والله
يا
زق
عروج دقيقه واحده بس اللي دعوا للخروج
كانوا قاعدين في
بيوتهم
الشباب
ع اشكرك شكرا جزيلا محمود عطيه المحامي
رئيس ائتلاف مصر فوق الجميع واشكر سليم
عزوز الكاتب الصحفي واشكركم مشاهدينا على
حسن المتابعه والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه